hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the biological
basis of ethics Peter Singer discusses a
number of different overlapping forms of
altruism altruism is behavior that is
motivated by the welfare or well-being
or prevention of harm to another often
at the sacrifice of one's own interests
but although not always necessarily so
and he talks about kin altruism as
something that's very demonstrably there
in most human beings and which plays a
major role in ethical decision making
whether it should or shouldn't that's
that's a different topic he also talks
about reciprocal altruism where we
behave altruistically towards those who
behave altruistically towards us for the
most part and those who don't we shut
them out or punish them or feel
indignant to them in some way and that's
still more or less at the level of
individual relations and then there's
what he calls group altruism where we're
considering those who belong to a group
that we identify with as worthy of our
altruistic or beneficent behavior and
those who are
as not being so worthy and we behave in
that way and all three of these
intersect with and interact with each
other they can be understood to some
degree as expanding circles and this
comes from his book the expanding circle
so that's not an idea that's unique of
course to singer that goes all the way
back to ancient thinking in in both the
Western tradition and also in various
non-western moral theories as well so
singer is going to talk about group
altruism and the role that it plays in
ethics he says in the previous chapter
of his book we saw that most socio
biologists believe that kin selection
and reciprocity were more significant
forces in evolution than group selection
he's interested in how we we came about
to be beings that favored those in our
group but he says nevertheless we found
some grounds for believing group
selection might have played a role and
he says that we can put aside non-human
animals we're not going to worry about
that when we look at human ethical
systems the case for group selection is
much stronger although in view of the
clear interest each society has in
promoting devotion to the group it is
here even harder than in most cases to
disentangle biological and cultural
influences so what can we actually say
about that he says we can say from the
biological side early humans lived in
small groups and these were often
reproductively isolated from each other
by geography or mutual hostility so
conditions necessary for selection on a
group basis existed he's not that's a
fairly weak claim he's not saying that
this is automatically how you know human
evolution worked and how it influenced
our psychology or anything like that
you're just saying listen this is the
conditions that we started out in and
that's what we you know ended up with
can we find a link along the way so
let's think about what he says about
group altruism as I put it out he views
it as
something different from but often
reinforcing kin and reciprocal altruism
although there can be a lot of dilemmas
as we see in you know ethics where
reciprocity or kin altruism could be
opposed to group altruism we should
always prevent stealing within the group
but my kid is stealing and I don't want
to turn them in now we've got a conflict
between Ken and group altruism so what
is group altruism he talks about two
sides to this one part is loyalty to the
group as such as opposed to simply to
the members of the group there's
something that goes beyond the mere
aggregate or gathering together of
individuals who share some sort of
common property that produces a loyalty
which could be viewed as higher could be
viewed as more expansive we'll get to
that in a moment that produces the this
sense of loyalty willingness to to be
altruistic to the group as a whole to
sacrifice one's interests for those of
the group and so he says that there we
go
once the obligations of kinship are
fulfilled the boundaries of our own
expand to the next largest community
with which we identify and he says
beyond this this priority of a concern
for the welfare of others of our
background you know our particular group
there is a loyalty to the group as a
whole which is distinct from the loyalty
to the individual members we tend to
identify with a group and see its
fortunes as to some degree our fortunes
and that's you know he doesn't go much
further into depth with it but that's a
really good way of describing what's
going on when we see people behaving
altruistically towards their group as a
whole there's usually some sort of way
in which they're getting something out
of it could be that they're getting
prestige because of being the the great
hero or
you know devoted person or sacrifice or
something like that but they also view
that group as in a certain way
identified with themselves they they
find themselves within the group or you
know in the case of particularly
narcissistic individuals the group may
simply be a reflection of their own
glory or something like that so he says
that this is this is quite important and
plays a major role in our life so
there's a loyalty to the group as a
whole
often this also involves a hostility
towards those who don't belong to the
group or to other groups so there's
what's often been called a
us-versus-them mentality that can
accompany group altruism and indeed in
many empirical cases can be shown to be
there another important point that he
makes and I think this is even more
important in our 21st century present
than perhaps in you know the distant
past is that the group that we're
identifying with and feeling a sort of
altruism about does not have to be a
local or regional grouping what do we
mean by a local or regional grouping
identifying with your village
identifying with your tribe your clan
your grouping you know with in ancient
Athens with your deem right the
neighborhood that you belong to which is
also connected with with kinship ties
and things like that but when in which
you may have been adopted
regional groupings what are we talking
about there well you know being a in my
case residents of Milwaukee Milwaukee in
or a Wisconsin night or an American
right or a North American right or
however we're going to figure it those
are in fact affiliations and
identifications and we're not saying
that those aren't matters for group
altruism but there is the possibility of
groups that aren't bound in
space in that way he says that it could
be an affiliation based not on living in
the same area but on a shared
characteristic what are some examples he
brings up ethnic or class background or
religious belief these can be incredibly
powerful ways of tying people together
that extend you know far past any sort
of geographical boundaries and
oftentimes transcend them in their
importance
singer brings up patriotism as an
interesting example to look at from an
ethical perspective he says that you
know the persistence of group loyalty in
modern times is is only too clearly
demonstrated by ways in which patriotism
could could go drastically wrong
Hitler's success in arousing
nationalistic feelings of the German
people got to admit that he had a lot of
assistance from people it wasn't just
him Stalin's need to appeal to Mother
Russia rather than the defense of
communism to rally the citizens of the
Soviet Union to the war effort and then
he says in a less sinister way so this
is you know not just those sorts of
drastic examples we can witness the
appeal of group loyalty every weekend by
watching the behavior of the crowds and
football games he has in mind of course
soccer and but we can think about
American football as a prime example of
this there's you know here in the United
States we have some rivalries so people
come up from the next state over here to
Wisconsin with Illinois license plates
and they get called things like fibs you
can look up what that means if you want
to and you know people who are wearing
green and gold may say to people who are
wearing blue and orange
the Bears suck right and if you go down
to Chicago well you know they don't like
the Packers there as well now these are
irrational group
loyalties are they not but they play a
role in in moral life there are people
who think themselves entitled to behave
in certain ways towards the other ways
that are not altruistic but actually
hostile to them and then there are with
ways in which people behave
altruistically to those who they view as
being on the same team as them in some
way so it's used an example I'm driving
along and I see you know somebody's car
broken down and they're looking for help
and they happen to have a big Packers
flag on their their car in some way you
know perhaps hanging from the radio
antenna and I pull over and I say go
pack and I get out and I start helping
them with their stuff whereas if you
know I'm driving along now I I actually
personally would help a Bears fan but I
could well imagine some people driving
past seeing the Illinois license plates
a Bears flag and giving them the finger
as they as they drive past that's an
example of group loyalty affecting
whether one is altruistic or not rather
silly example but you know we see that
coming back to patriotism if we think
about how patriotism works is it really
going to be a rational thing he says our
ethical codes reflect group feelings in
two ways corresponding the difference
between group altruism manifested as a
preference for altruism directed towards
individual members of one's own group
the sort of examples I was giving just a
moment ago and group altruism manifested
as loyalty to the group as a whole so
let's take the sports analogy again on
Twitter the you know Packer nation says
that I should retweet this thing and try
to get as much awareness for whatever's
going on some fundraising effort or
something like that for my my team I
retweet it and I say go pack go write
with the hashtag and all of that sort of
stuff that's that that's group loyalty
there
it's manifesting in altruistic action
for the group not much in that case
right it doesn't really cost me anything
to retweet something and I may actually
get some something out of it but there
could be other demands that are made and
indeed when it comes to patriotism very
often significant demands get made upon
people so he says that you know going on
a little bit the group bias of our
ethics in respect to loyalty to the
group shows itself in the high praise we
give to patriotism and he says this is a
great question why is it that my country
right or wrong can be taken seriously
and he means can be taken seriously from
an ethical perspective how is it that we
can actually say my country look at
there there's a affirmation right or
wrong so even if my country is doing the
wrong thing I'm going to support it
because that's the right thing for me to
do there's a weird paradox there too
patriotism is there not he says why do
we regard patriotism as a virtue at all
we disapprove of selfish behavior but we
approve of and indeed encourage group
selfishness and gild it with the name of
patriotism here he gives a prime example
something that's been quite
controversial lately and and ought to be
so he says we erect statues to those who
fought and died for our country
irrespective of the merits of the war in
which they fought one of the reasons why
Robert Ely leader of the Confederate
Army in the Civil War is such an admired
figure in American history is that he
put his loyalty to his native Virginian
above his publicly stated moral doubts
about slavery and we could go much
deeper into discussion about that
suffice it to say that not too many
people up here in the North actually buy
into that singers from Australia so you
can you know be it's understandable that
he doesn't understand all of the day the
dynamics of this but if you go down
south there are quite a few people who
feel that you know you they may condemn
racism slavery Jim Crow all of this sort
of stuff but they'll still say that it's
it's an important part of their history
and heritage and they'll hold him up as
in some ways a moral exemplar view that
many of us up here do not share by the
way he points out that there's there's
other ethical points of view that are
very critical of patriotism he talks
about the most enlightened and
progressive thinkers like Diogenes the
cynic who declared himself to be a
citizen not of one country but of the
whole world
that's what cosmopolitanism actually
means the world is my polis the cosmos
is my country my nation which means that
I don't identify with this particular
place and it's productivities and its
history and you know its feelings about
right and wrong which are often quite
wrong but rather I look at things that a
more universalistic sense appeals to
universal values he brings up the Stoics
seneca and marcus aurelius argue that
our loyalty should be to the world
community not to the state in which we
happen to be born now marcus aurelius of
course it was an emperor Seneca served
an emperor not a particularly good one
so this is a little bit tempered but you
can find other stoic saying similar
things as well well ter goethe and
schiller express similar ideas of world
rather than national citizenship and it
says so if people have realized that
there really is you know one race the
human race humanity as such
why is group altruism still so strong
strong enough to be this thing that we
call patriotism
and you know maybe there's some sort of
basis for it that is not a purely
rational basis but does in fact impinge
upon ethics he says that patriotism has
proved difficult to dislodge from its
high place among the conventionally
accepted virtues the explanation for
this could be that patriotism rests at
least in part on a biological Bey
but the explanation could also be
cultural in both cases there would be an
adaptiveness to patriotism to group
altruism in that respect and he says
listen we're not actually going to be
able to identify precisely what the
evolutionary basis of patriotism is most
likely there's a complex interaction
between the two of them and he says
biological and cultural explanations are
not inconsistent unless foolishly we try
to insist that one of these two is the
sole cause of a complex piece of
behavior and he says that's very
unlikely then he also points out that
one other thing about about patriotism
that some things that may have a more
biological basis for example preference
for one's own ethnic community or type
or whatever that's that's going to be
may have a stronger biological basis
than patriotism does but he points out
in a multiracial society strong racial
feelings are disadvantaged strong
patriotic feelings however are not which
could you know lend some credence to the
idea that patriotism is perhaps more on
the cultural side less on the biological
side wherever it comes from it is
something that we do have to be a bit
wary about and and really any sort of
group identification that produces
altruism to members of the group and
something other than altruism like
hostility to members to people who are
not members of that group or are members
of other groups is something that we
want to be careful about from an ethical
perspective
you